[Music]
the what podcast switchbands this year
that matter uh going through some of our
artist interviews hours i wasn't there
from bonnaroo 2022 in what we call a
snackable
pocket-sized episode uh berry quarter
lord taco uh we have one interview
that's out there bristol moroni we also
have today's which is
churches um i really feel like church is
one of the uh the highlights of the
festival now uh i would have gone it
would have been on top of my list
because i love that live show so much
barry taco do you like the show
yes
he saw more of it than i did oh you
actually did go okay
yeah i saw a little bit of it yeah but
uh
i i liked them the interview was
terrific this was the one i i teased a
little bit uh the last show the bigger
show that we did uh we looked like we
knew what we were doing we we came in
with two photographers and a sound guy
and
a whole crew and they were very nice and
uh
met with us inside their air-conditioned
trailer
backstage which did you trash it
yeah so we had a rager as soon as they
left taco and i just tore the place
apart oh yeah you know open tables tear
and post as you should
you should
i you know that we've told this story
before we've told the story before of
when i trashed
uh bishop briggs's is uh
trailer and oh totally by accident it
was not my fault but i don't know if i
told you but
yes it kind of was it never was my fault
she asked for a topo chico i went to
open the topo chico and the whole
cabinet came flying down was it my fault
it's kind of not how it went
she was insistent that she was so proud
that that she had the topo chico that's
what she was loving she loved her
trailer and she got all the type of
chico she could drink and
she kept insisting you guys need to take
one you need to take one well it was it
was not a screw cab
so brad's like uh you know the old
college you put it on the side of the
table and you hit
and you pop and they broke the table
the whole front of the table came
crashing down
the other train
no no i was opening it for her i was
being a gentleman
i said would you like to have a topo
chico miss miss bishop briggs and i went
to open it and then it it
broke the place in half and then i was
like i'll just get you another one i'll
get you another one and then i went back
to the topo chico stack yeah opened it
it flew out of my hand got choked
pochico everywhere on the thing
she just looked down at the ground in a
toppo chico covered ground and a bottle
that was sprawled over there
and she just looked at me and she goes
uh
just go just go yeah you're like i'll
clean it up i cleaned up she said just
go
i couldn't pack ups or stuff quickly
enough just go
i i
so i i ran into her in the city a couple
of weeks ago and i uh i brought that
story up to her and she goes do you know
what i haven't had a topo chico since
they're ruined forever now
she literally looked at me it's like i
think that was the last table of cheek
that i'll ever
send me a picture of it i'll text it to
her that's fantastic i'll send it to
taco well i need to include it in the in
the video here yeah yeah we'll toss it
in the video right here
it was not one of my finer moments but
it was not my fault
it was a shoddy construction of a
cabinet that should not have been
breaking just because i was trying to
open a bottle okay well
she had nothing to open the topography
i needed to be
the big strong man for her
it was pretty funny she's pregnant too
by the way she's about to have a baby
beautiful pregnant well i mean she is oh
that's that's not your fault either
though right i would that was definitely
not mine
either
she's a i think that there's some women
that just look great pregnant right and
she looks incredible i don't mean that
disparagingly she looks incredible i
mean she just shines she's got this glow
on her she thinks that she looks like
she's having the time of her life
pregnant uh
yeah she's got it i i love her i think
she's fantastic it was great but uh
back to churches with lauren ian and
martin they were nice as they could be
um
we talked about the heat because uh she
said you know here i am wearing this
wool dress and yeah i bet she was i bet
she was about to ask what she was
wearing because i mean the big thing
about church is she's she's a fashion
icon well and she was i mean they were
ready to go well pretty much i think
martin uh was not he said i'll change
when it's almost time
but uh
she was beautiful and they were again uh
david bruce was with us i am bonnaroo
and nate gale was with us taking
pictures and dave they went outside uh
with david and
posed for a couple three minutes four or
five minutes that's great the other
thing too i love about her is that she's
got this
massive voice i mean her voice is huge
and she is a teeny tiny little she's
very very tiny she is an itty-bitty tiny
little uh pixie and adorable too
absolutely adorable the sweetest um you
know yeah but boy she's got that voice
how that voice is packed into that
into her is insane to me and you'll hear
uh this was their third bonnaroo right
so they compared that's right yeah
compared their first two and uh and and
they were just getting ready when they
talked to us for their
for their third which as we you know
that's one of the things we love about
bonnaroo is you get these repeat uh acts
and you get to catch up with them and
and watch that develop and all that but
that was really cool that was that was
one of the highlights for me i mean it's
work related not everybody gets that
opportunity but
that was a lot of fun also uh i don't
know if you know this but somebody that
we know very very well will be listening
to this episode who is a major major
churches fan you want to guess who it is
big time celebrity gonna be listening to
this episode i don't know
um that would be a miss kristen quarter
she
loves
so i'm not going to tell them that this
is happening so if they hear it i'm sure
this is their sign this is the closed
caption message
to the jared and kristen quarter family
of repeat repeat yeah cool yeah
that was a lot of fun wasn't it taco you
had seen him
he asked about that he had seen him at
shaky knees
yeah i just caught their show shakings
it was fantastic it was one of the best
shows of the weekend
it's a great show um and uh so anything
else if you want to get into this uh to
this chat no just okay look forward to
hearing it and every by the way
everything went great the sound was good
we hit record yes
everything looked great it was very we
looked like we knew what we were doing
it was cool uh-huh
well
it's bound to get one bound to get one
this was the one yeah congratulations
guys church is on what podcast
[Music]
all right guys welcome back to the what
podcast i'm barry across from me is lord
taco you all know
i'm sure you know the folks sitting on
the couch we're so proud so honored to
have churches with us
thank you for having us yeah we're
backstage you guys are staying cool
getting ready for your show later trying
to yeah i don't know we were wearing
black and wool why have i done that
you know it's funny you mentioned that
i've always wondered it it's kind of a
it's got to be a tricky thing for a band
right because you got to look cool you
got to you've got a thresher you can't
yeah you can't really wear what you
would want to wear in this kind of
weather because then it's not fit with
the image of the band you know yeah i
don't know i don't know i'm kind of just
at that point of the tour where i'm like
[ __ ]
whatever you've got the shorts on get
changed for the show
wear whatever is comfortable that's the
bonnaroo way
you guys we were talking before uh we
went on the air here uh this is your
third time right it's our time yes i
think uh we were just looked up to
double check 2014 was the first time
and then 2018 uh we played and hayley
williams could sing with us on a song
well we got to sing with her i don't
know where this sounds bad and then this
time so lucky number three what are your
memories of those two shows and what are
you looking forward to for this one
gosh it's a bit of a blur that's 2014
seems like so long ago
remember kanye was playing that night
like 2014 bonnaroo will i'll never
forget
because it was the the night that like i
injured my back
during the show
and uh like i had the same recurring
back injury for like 10 years after like
i still have it
oh the crowd was so crazy
and the show was so crazy that it was
like
i was just having a bit too much fun wow
you know like i felt felt something go
oh man that's a bit weird in the middle
of the gig it's like that doesn't feel
right and then the next day i was like
stiff as a board and i couldn't move
so i'll never forget it taco and i were
talking beforehand he saw you guys uh
what a couple weeks ago
yeah for shaking these i was there for
you there and i caught your show there
it was amazing perfect another sweaty
situation isn't it
um apparently i didn't see but
apparently trent resner watched a little
bit of our set oh did he and i i'm glad
i didn't know that all the time because
i would have been extra nervous that
would have been awful had we known he
was actually watching us we would have
made so many mistakes then he left so
maybe he didn't like it
that's the scariest thing of all if
someone only watches a little bit of
your set does that mean that they hate
you
i like to believe he just had
commitments he's a very busy man oh yeah
yeah he was going to play a show so i
guess he had to go and get ready that's
what we're telling ourselves anyway
what are you looking forward to go ahead
i'm sorry yeah no i watched the whole
thing it was great i'm glad i didn't
make you any nervous that i was watching
it yeah
if you didn't know taco left earlier
no it's going to be so embarrassing when
we talk to him in two weeks
what are you looking forward to in this
one now that you've done it
do those sorts of things play into
i guess your mindset or your thinking
you know what a you know it's gonna be
hot you know the crowd's gonna be into
it and ready to see stuff do those
things do you think about those sort of
things in a place like this
i think no yeah i mean totally but now
instead of being
uh
truly terrified as i might have been
like in the early days it's more just
excitement now
like nervous energy but the good kind of
nervous energy where when we first came
around things happened really fast so
we found ourselves on these stages that
you know maybe we would have considered
to be too big for us or maybe i thought
personally everyone is an imposter you
know
but we did a lot of growing up in front
of people yeah but now i'm just when we
play when we think about tonight it's
just
fun not
oh my god not the same feeling as 2014.
it's interesting you say that i talked
to kane brown who's a country singer
from chattanooga and he said basically
it's almost like sports where you hear
the you know the game slowed down
the first year or two for him he just
wanted to get on stage
and that was it you know get through it
and he now he he wants to make jokes and
talk and enjoy and think about it is
that kind of what you're
yeah yeah i think we were just
i guess it's interesting because it's
coming around to 10 years of the first
album so it's been nice to kind of
reflect on that time period a bit and be
like huh we were just like terrified the
whole time so yeah it's nice to be able
to think about it a bit differently and
be terrified about different things
we were talking about the years and you
guys this is your third it's you know my
17th
one of the things we love about coming
to bonnaroo is to be able to see bands
multiple times
as they
grow and progress and all that so it
works both ways i guess is
well all right taco do you have any
other questions i know you guys are on a
tight schedule yeah no i'm just looking
forward to your show tonight yeah thank
you and thank you guys for having us
thank you so so much for doing this we
really appreciate it
thanks everybody
[Music]
a consequence podcast network exclusive
churches on the what podcast uh barry
taco nice job because the pictures look
great too by the way if you haven't
checked those out i guess we'll social
them the what underscore podcast or is
it the underscore what podcast i never
remember
the what underscore podcast on twitter
and the what podcast on instagram and
everywhere else
like share subscribe
rate review uh it's all very helpful uh
good work gentlemen
looks great now barry i i will say
the pictures are great but
you look a little underdressed next to
her
you look a little
you know there's times in life
there are times in life when you have a
chance to look back and
rethink
some things and
at that time in
my life i was concerned about only the
heat got it and i wasn't thinking about
what it's going to look like for the
rest of eternity
what did i tell you i look like a giant
keebler
[Laughter]
this quiver really smokes a lot of weed
the bandana is a big part of bonnaroo
for me because it keeps the hair out of
the way see this is the problem i
actually don't agree with the strategy
barry
why would you cover up the money maker
do you see me wearing a hat at bonner
room
no
see and that's
again i'm rethinking it now now that now
that there are cameras involved
i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to find a different way
because you have such a head of hair hey
you don't ever want to tame that and
secondly if you if you put it under a
bandana wouldn't it just make it hotter
now actually it felt brutally good
interesting
but yeah it was uh
yeah if you're hair and makeup
you're just listening to this on the
audio version hop over to youtube and
come check out uh
come see el fudge on the what podcast
swear to god if we don't get a photoshop
version of of you and keep the elves i'm
gonna be so mad i'm gonna be so
i demand that i demand somebody make
that
photoshop please god
i i it is what it is after you know i
saw it that looked like a giant elf
[Laughter]
wait a second
would a giant elf considering an
elephant isn't out would a giant elf be
a berry
maybe i don't know full grown i don't
know yeah a full-grown elf is a bear
not a baby a berry
[Laughter]
um but speaking of artwork you know i
kept running into aaron carlson at the
farm and he was one of our patreons we
had him on the show and he was the one
that drew
that masterpiece for the contest where
he just went into ms paint and just you
know sketched out you know you and me
and or you and barry and and then i was
just like a miller high life
well your favorite beer oh yeah yeah
yeah that's fantastic yeah so what was
he doing there whipping up another piece
of art was he uh what was he doing on
the fly
was he printing t-shirts what was his uh
gig on the farm
i i don't know how to sell something
well it was just weird i kept running
into him you know and there's you know
just well it's not hard to i know it's
not hard to run into people when you're
basically at a family picnic
where there's there's not many people
you ran into a lot of 50 000 people here
and you keep running into i mean i sorry
i ran into every single day it seemed
like in different places
that's different shows you know walking
backstage
uh i think he had one of the platinum
wristbands on or something
well did wait did he do platinum
yeah i think so maybe yeah
maybe yeah i would like to find one of
the four or five people that did
platinum this year that would have i'd
love to hear their experience in my
campsite
yeah i want to grill them for stealing
our real estate that's a good idea
yeah i wanted to see if they felt shame
and i hope they appreciated it
it's like when somebody breaks into the
house just to hang out the pool uh i
hope you're enjoying it i really hope
you're enjoying what we what we built
with our hands and our labor yeah
seriously though if you did uh platinum
and you're listening uh reach out i'd
love to talk to you yeah no kidding i'd
like to know and i'd like to know what
was
good bad whatever about it if you do it
again
because that's
a big price tag
yeah
say no so that we can get our campground
back no kidding
eliminate platinum that's our new thing
move platinum moving back to the hill or
another hill all right there you go uh
churches on the what podcast
we'll see you soon
[Music]
consequence podcast network